well I got to mention this this is from
the military times it says Pentagon
attributes UFO sightings to spies and
Airborne trash
that's no way to speak about aliens
intelligence officials are set to
deliver Congress a new report today this
was yesterday so they already delivered
it I guess on unexplained aerial
phenomenon better known as UFOs the
document from the office of the Director
of National Intelligence will provide an
update to a report the intelligence
agency made public in June June of 2021
which explored more than 140 incidents
of UAP encounters between
2004-2021. despite calls for greater
transparency from lawmakers and military
leaders it's not yet clear which
contents of the coming report will be
made public while it could offer more
detailed explanations into the surge of
recent sightings defensive Farm
officials are downplaying theories of
alien invasions and emphasizing ordinary
objects that they say are more likely to
blame
military officials stole the New York
Times that post uh that most resolved
UFO cases can be attributed to foreign
spies or Airborne trash
okay I want to know about the Airborne
trash so there's trash in the sky
speeding along at the speed of sound
changing directions mid-flight
where's this trash coming from
is it trash that the aliens have thrown
out of their UFOs
uh maybe they'll explain that how that
works exactly in May during congress's
first public UFO Hearing in more than 50
years Pentagon officials testified that
a video with mysterious glowing green
triangles actually displayed drones that
were shot through night vision lenses
sure in another video referred to as go
fast an unknown object appear to move at
incredible speed military officials
later debunked the video as an illusion
created by the angle of observation
against water oh come on
so where's the trash part of it are they
going to even explain in this article
how trash could
what is what's what is the trash doing
40 000 feet in the air and how is it
moving that way and what kind of trash
is this
are these plastic straws have the
plastic straw problem gotten that bad
that now they're they're whizzing
through the sky too
um
skimming ahead
no they don't revisit that they don't
revisit in the article they never
explain they just oh that's probably
Airborne trash
what do you mean Airborne trash yeah
just you know just trash because
sometimes
you bring your uh
garbage cans out to the curb and then
you come in the morning you come out in
the morning and they're gone and you
think that like the trash man took them
away but like sometimes they'll just
they'll fly up into the sky and you know
and and
and freak out Navy Pilots it happens
sometimes I guess
this is ridiculous you know what this
makes me more convinced that you're
talking about conspiracy theories okay
here's one this makes me more convinced
than ever that aliens not only are real
which is a which is just a fact but have
been to Earth because now there was a
moment
I was actually I was less convinced back
when it seemed that the government was
being open about it and they started
talking about it and they said yeah
we'll talk about aliens and then I
thought well okay this is not they
wouldn't something's not right here but
now they're retrenching again and
they're and they're you know yeah we've
debunked it don't worry about it
never mind
that yeah they've explained the ones
that they can explain with normal you
know which just in by pointing to normal
expected physical phenomena so they've
explained the ones that can be explained
okay I get that big big breaking news
there
but there's still The Lion's Share of
these sightings that have never been
explained
and those are the ones who are
interested in
and again I really want to understand
how Tre how you can blame this on trash
it's uh you know someone threw a Coke
can into the air and then the light
refracting from Jupiter and bouncing off
of the ocean created a
uh it's a a hallucination type effect
and this okay right
and that'll do it for us for this
portion of the show as we move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]